你心里要有一本账，
我是5万还是8万，
我这5万8万就是一个基金，
就这意思啊，
但是不能让他得寸进尺啊，
大的方向，
大的财产权利，
大的角色，
不能让他得进尺。
我俩结婚10年，
有一个5岁的女儿，
我们两个人呢，
都是出身农村，
公公婆婆，
我的爸爸妈妈，
我们都是朴实能干的母女，
没有婆媳矛盾，
公婆婆对我也是特别认可，
我小时候啊学习非常的努力，
然后就立志给父母在城里那个买房，
安享晚年，
我工作五年之后呢，
我这个梦想有实现，
我就是给我爸爸妈妈在这个城市里面买了房子，
爸爸妈妈现在也是过得非常的幸福，
我女儿三岁前是由我妈妈啊帮忙带大的，
现在主要就是女儿长大已经上幼儿园了，
就我和我老公，
我们俩自己亲自带家务，
这块呢，
基本就是啊，
我老公请担，
就例如孩子的衣服呀，
拖地呀，
偶尔做饭了，
这块都是我老公做的比较多，
然后我几乎是不做家务，
家里乱了的话会请阿姨，
我在刚结婚的时候，
那个时候我年薪差不多是20万，
然后我老公年薪是在5万左右，
比如说一个月4000多，
我现在年薪是100多，
我还在这个持续学习以及提升，
凭这个行业身高和专业型为，
我感觉我未来也有可能是年薪二百，
三百甚至500，
我感觉我还是很努力的，
我感觉我的情商是不如我老公的，
家里很多事啊都是。
我老公操心我的主要精力就主要就是用在工作上，
他这么多年的收入呢，
没有变化，
依旧我还是年薪5万左右，
然后我的消费呢是比较节俭，
并前我是有存款的，
然后他是月光族，
婚前是没有存款，
我们俩结婚之后呢，
他欠了4万哥的这个装修外债，
这个是我婚后才知道的，
因为我结婚的时候我也没问他有多少存款，
我也没好意思思问啊，
所以我们俩结婚前几年就是常常因为这个经济吵架，
家里的这个开销啊，
孩子幼儿园的费用啊，
以及大额支出主要都是靠我，
我老公也没有什么不良嗜好，
偶尔也会给我情绪价值，
过节也会给我准备礼物，
现在他主要就是还房贷，
之前家里刚结婚的时候，
我有一辆十几万的代步车，
他总说没有面子，
老是磨我换车，
他天天磨我，
也特别烦，
我换了一个40多万的车，
买完之后呢，
我也是，
我就越想越气啊，
买个贵的车干什么，
也经常因为这个车吵架，
今年呢，
他一共给了我1万块钱，
但是他偶尔也会给家里买东西啊，
他给孩子买衣服呀啊等，
开销稍微多一点，
有的时候他确实也会让我转回去，
所以他给我这一万多块钱，
我陆陆续续给他转回去，
我差不多给他转一万三四吧，
毕竟他快过生日了，
他自己然后花了5000多买了一件衣服，
我就觉得他的收入和消费不匹配，
我就特别生气，
我们也常常因为这个经济问题特别内耗。
我的性格是。
因为小女人心眼儿比较小啊，
甜肯就是一直希望老公能力啊比我强，
赚钱能力也比我多，
但是这么多年发现很难实现，
我现在我已经完全接受了，
我也知道我现在也很难改变她的消费观，
其实他今年也就买了一件，
就是这么一件贵的衣服，
我也不想分手，
想咨询我怎么才能和他好好相处，
怎么才能停止那号，
怎么跟他好好相处啊？
我俩总是因为经济吵架，
他后为买点贵的我就是不太高兴，
因为家里的主要支出在于我，
实话说啊，
一年挣五六万块钱的人，
自己过生日花5000块钱买衣服，
这个事儿我觉得我也挺看不上眼，
就是日子不该这么过。
某种程度上来说的话，
可能我们也很难理解他的这种虚荣心，
也很难理解他的这种要面子，
因为人和人阶段不一样，
人和人看到的风景不一样，
人和人看到的世界的善意恶意不一样，
可能在他的世界里面，
他必须要开一个40万的车出去，
人家门卫的大爷才对他客气一点，
旁边的那些同事才对他稍微的高看一眼，
可能他就需要这样的养分，
他才能够开开心心的过这一天。
我是这么看待这个问题的啊，
既然你不想跟他分开，
既然想要好好的过日子，
那有的时候你就想象一下，
如果说你是你老公，
就一个月就挣那么几千块钱，
他被。
给门口的大爷瞧不起，
被单位的同事瞧不起，
他或许真的需要一点装点门面的东西，
他才能快乐呢。
有的时候我们花点钱买的是他的一份快乐，
他高兴了回来不找我的麻烦，
不给我添堵，
不找孩子的麻烦。
你花钱解决的是一个心情问题，
花钱解决的是一个让全家人不被一个人的自卑，
一个人的虚荣没有得到满足而拉低气压的问题，
那某种程度上，
你每年要花出一笔预算，
这笔预算我就是要买全家人的这样一个高薪的氛围的，
你这么想问题吧，
对不对？
因为他如果在单位上能力瞧不起他，
同事瞧不起他，
领导瞧不起他，
他心情就会不好，
他心情不好难免会影响到孩子，
我就算为了孩子有一个好心情，
我就每年花点预算买的，
就是一个好心情，
就这么小问题，
不要买这个衣服之之前我都看了，
是就是3000来块钱，
我说你要喜欢，
我给你买了也行，
结果他买了个5000多的，
我就特别生气，
我说那我只能给你转3000，
剩下你自己看着办，
那你像他剩下晚上也可以过生日了，
我是直接给他把5000多转给他，
还是我就按照原来允诺的就给他3000，
剩下2000万自己解决呢？
他那个衣服还没买是不是其实他都已有买，
但还一直没有传，
我看了衣服我也来气，
然后他也没传，
我觉得是这样的啊，
就是说你一年挣100万，
你在心里划出一个份额，
比如说。
经你就花出5万块钱，
我这5万块钱就要买，
我全家人高高兴兴的，
他就是一种精神消费，
你就别想他是买了一件衣服，
他买的是一个高兴，
买的是一个家庭的氛围，
买的是一个家庭的和睦和和谐，
别想它买的是一件衣服，
衣服它只是一个象征，
就这件衣服它只是一个象征，
你把这件衣服幻化成我买的是你高兴，
我买的是一个家庭和谐，
我买的是我孩子有个高兴的爸爸，
你这么想问题，
那我就把这裙子还给他啊，
可以我们俩以后的这三手当中，
我还是说尽量满足他呗，
你心里要有一本账，
我是5万还是8万，
我这5万8万就是一个基金，
就这意思啊，
但是不能让他得寸进尺啊，
大的方向，
大的财产权利，
大的角色，
不能让他得寸进尺，
我能明白，
其实我们俩结婚这几年呢，
我们俩现在有两套房，
一辆车，
目前住这套房有一点点贷款，
一年入还清，
其实我们都没有贷款，
我也看评论了，
而且我有点抠门，
因为这么多年我就靠自己打拼了，
我想换车换房全是靠我一己之力，
所以我压力比较大，
我女儿马上也快上小学了，
我还想给我女儿买一个学区房，
然后这学区房也挺贵的，
我就感觉刚喘口气，
我又要花一大笔子的费用，
压力有点大吧，
相对来说其实己比较抠，
对他可能也有一点抠门吧，
谁不抠门我还抠门呢，
反正我们这种过过苦日子的，
从小这么一点一点挣扎，
向上挣扎向前一。
点一点日子过好的，
没有不抠门的，
都抠门啊，
抠门不是什么坏事儿了，
好的，
我姐，
行，
那我们调整心态吧，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜谢。
我看到有很多人说龙飞劝的很勉强，
不是的，
是因为这个姐妹她的目标是明确的，
人家很知道自己想要什么，
人家要的就是家庭和睦，
要的就是调整心态，
要的就是好好过日子，
人家没说不要这个男的，
所以我是基于这样一个大前提，
既然没说不要这个男的，
是不是两口子人家想好好过日子，
那真的会挣钱的女人啊，
有钱的女人都给我听好了好吗？
有钱的女人你也要有一点有钱的女人的自我修养，
就有钱的女人要学会花钱买情绪，
学会花钱买快乐，
不要误解我啊，
不要误解我说王慧姐教大家要花钱买快乐，
到时候传的到处都是，
我菲姐要花钱买快乐了啊，
不是那些意思啊，
生怕在网络上，
到时候有什么舆情，
记得点赞关注哦。